one month since russia's invasion
ukrainian forces are fighting back and
gaining ground
on thursday sinking a russian ship in
the azov sea near berdyansk in the south
but in mario poll russian forces
continue to pound residential areas
and residents there continue to take
stock of the destruction of their city
the worst hit so far
people are now managing to trickle out
and help is beginning to trickle in
we've been receiving humanitarian aid
already they bought us some bread
dippers for the kids we've received
oatmeal for little baby we just found
out that they are handing out eight and
came here you don't always know and when
you come it's too late
the city of chernigev north east of kiev
like so many places one month after the
start of this war
is unrecognizable
it breaks my heart
hearts of all ukrainians and every free
person on the planet that's why i ask
you to stand against the war come from
your offices your homes your schools and
universities come in the name of peace
come with ukrainian symbols to support
ukraine to support freedom to support
life
come to your squares your streets make
yourselves visible and heard
an appeal from ukraine's president a
global call to mobilize to stop the war
la vie of the city leve the region key
to ukraine's war effort as a corridor
for military assistance from allies in
the west and as a place to help people
romania
we need water to be over and to go back
home
today is my child's birthday and we are
here
she's 10 years old we really want to go
home
you know that feeling when your child is
begging you please father save me i want
to leave we lived like that for two
weeks he decided to live by ourselves
nobody could help us nobody could reach
us and help us to create because all the
time airplanes were flying over our
heads it was very scary
vladimir zielinski's wartime leadership
has helped his popularity
but will it hold if the war goes on
[Music]
and ukrainians continue to pay the
highest price to defend their country
zane basravi al-jazeera leve